good afternoon everyone i'm pleased to
be here today with dr hinshaw to provide
albertans with an update on covet 19 in
the province
before i get into the latest trends i
want to address the speculation i've
heard about alberta's rapid test program
coming to an end at alberta's pharmacies
these rumors are not correct
free rapid tests continue to be
available to all albertans as of april
12th alberta has distributed more than
40 million rapid tests including 14.9
million for individual use
over a million tests have gone out to
pharmacies since march 28th
i encourage everyone to pick up kits for
their household so they're prepared if
symptoms develop
we have an ample supply of testing kits
and participating pharmacies can
continue to order them as needed to meet
demand
we've also had questions about changes
to compensation for pharmacies
last month we changed the compensation
model for rapid test kits from five
dollars per kit to sixty dollars per
case
the new fee reflects the fact that we
eliminated almost all the administrative
work for pharmacists who are providing
these test kits to albertans
now the previous process was time
consuming and some pharmacists chose not
to participate because of it
the current compensation model and the
process we have put in place is
appropriate for this process
pharmacies remain free to participate
and not all are choosing to do to do so
but i'm pleased to report that overall
we've seen an increase in the number of
rapid tests ordered over the past week
by pharmacies
tests remain widely available across the
province and as i said a moment ago more
than a million tests have been
distributed to pharmacies since march
28th the blue cross website lists
pharmacies that have stock and it's
updated frequently but not in real time
so if you're hoping to get tests at a
specific location please call ahead to
make sure that they have kits still in
stock
now to this week's update
dr hinshaw will share the specifics in a
moment but i'd like to speak to trends
from tuesday april 5th to monday april
11th
the average positivity rate for pcr
tests completed over the past seven days
is stable
it was 26.6
compared to 26.3 percent last week
however waste water virus levels are
trending up in calgary and edmonton and
in many of the smaller centers being
monitored although not all
we're seeing more virus circulating in
alberta as in other provinces
this is not surprising given the
transmissibility of ba2 and the increase
in contacts as people resume their
normal routines
that being said
we are so far not seeing any large
impact in terms of severe outcomes
hospitalizations due to coven 19 have
increased slightly from around a
thousand a month ago in mid-march to
about 1050
over the past week
we may see some further increase in the
next few weeks
but we are prepared for it and at this
time we do not expect
the kind of impact we saw in the initial
omicron wave in december and in january
we have high levels of vaccination and
recent exposure to omicron as well as
more access to new therapeutics
we also have a resilient healthcare
system with overall patient numbers that
are in line or lower than before covid
at the same time of year
overall hospital occupancy is stable
around 90 percent and admissions in icus
have been within their normal base of
173 beds on most days over the past
couple of weeks
100 occupancy in the icu's is still too
high and we still need surge spaces
staffed on a contingency basis but the
current level is a big change from the
kind of strain we've seen before
it's important for surgery in particular
and it's one reason the system is
continuing to do near normal surgery the
system remains very busy a couple of
sites in edmonton and calgary are still
over 100 occupancy that's in line with
some years before covet but it's still
too high
and ems remains under strain due to high
call volumes and also delays in handing
patients over in emergency because
volumes and emerge are very high as well
the whole system is busy and we're
working to increase capacity across our
entire system in the icus
in surgery
in diagnostic imaging in ems in
continuing care and in home care
we're going to see some increased
pressure from ba2 for a few weeks but
likely not what we saw in december in
january earlier this year
we will get past it and at the same time
we'll keep working to build a stronger
system with better access to care for
all albertans
so i want to once again thanks
give thanks to the dedication of our
health care professionals it's no longer
about waiting for the impact of coven 19
to pass
we are adding resources and increasing
access right now while we manage the
impact of ba2 and future variants if and
when we see them
at the same time we'll keep working to
minimize the impact of the virus by
getting more albertans vaccinated and
increasing access to paxlovit and
hopefully future therapeutics
that's what it means to transition to
living with covid19
not denying it or minimizing it but
controlling it and at the same time
doing the other work we need to do
yesterday was the first day for people
to book
or receive fourth doses
including albertans aged 70 and older
first nations inuit and metis people
aged 65 and older and all residents in
seniors congregate care facilities
provided that at least five months have
passed since their third dose
if you or someone you care about falls
into one of those groups please book an
appointment today it's quickly done
through the alberta vaccine booking
system online
by calling 811
or contacting your local pharmacy
directly we've seen an uptick in
bookings for the fourth doses just in
the past few days and i'm hopeful that
will continue
and i remind people to please get your
third dose if you are eligible
yesterday we also began offering
nufa sovid a non-mrna
option here in alberta
that's the vaccine from novavax and if
you've been waiting for it you can now
call 811 to book an appointment
as you know
vaccine is by far the most powerful tool
available to prevent albertans from
getting seriously ill from covet
we also have treatments available
including paxlovit and as of monday
approximately 720 pax-loved
prescriptions have been dispensed since
the drug became available on january
31st
thanks to increasing supply we expanded
eligibility last week
we currently have a supply of
approximately 16 000 courses of
treatment in place
and more are on the way
we expect to receive nearly 10 000 more
courses in the next week and another 11
000
later in april
now these treatments are not suitable
for everyone and clinicians and patients
need to work together to determine if
treatment is warranted however we'll do
everything we can to make them
accessible and readily available based
on the best clinical evidence and advice
and dr hinshaw may speak more on this
now thank you once again for attending
today and i'll now invite dr hinshaw to
the podium to provide the update
thank you minister and good afternoon
everyone
as the minister mentioned the numbers we
are sharing are from the reporting
period tuesday april 5th to monday april
11th
in those seven days our pcr test
positivity ranged from 23
to 29.8
currently there are
1053 people with coveted 19 in hospital
including 48 in the icu
sadly between april 5th and april 11th
an average about of about five deaths
per day related to covet 19 were
reported to alberta health
my sympathies go out to those grieving
the loss of these albertans and to
anyone grieving the loss of anyone from
any cause
as the minister mentioned the increases
we have been seeing are not unexpected
as measures have eased and regular
activities have started up again
we continue to track omicron and its
subvariant ba2 in our province as well
as evidence of the effectiveness of
different interventions related to
different variants
that is why we are making a small change
to antiviral coping 19 treatment in
alberta
beginning today we will be pausing the
use of sotrovimab as a treatment for
covid19
this follows uncertainty over whether
the sotrovamab treatment which is a
monoclonal antibody is effective against
the ba2 subvariant
currently ba2 is the dominant covit 19
variant in alberta making up more than
80 percent of all new cases so we have
had to shift our approach in treating it
if you have taken cetrova mab please be
assured that it is still a safe
medication and may provide some benefit
to those who have received it so there
is no concern for these individuals
going forward while we continue to
monitor the emerging evidence on cetrova
map we will be using both pakslovit and
remdezevir as options for those who can
benefit from early outpatient treatment
of covid19
paxlovid is a medication taken by mouth
and rem desevere is a medication
administered through iv infusions given
on a daily basis for three days
both medications will be accessed in the
same way
offered to those with a positive test
who are eligible after consultation with
a health care professional
these medications are most effective if
taken as soon as possible after symptoms
start
and must be started within five days of
showing symptoms
i encourage albertans to go online to
look at the eligibility criteria for
early treatment
as anyone who is eligible should seek
testing early when feeling mild symptoms
like a sore throat or fever
to be able to get the best benefit from
these medications
if you are in the eligible group and
you're feeling ill please go for testing
and call healthlink for more information
currently paxlovid and other antivirals
are for those who are most at risk
because of their medical conditions
vaccination status and age
we will continue to monitor the evidence
and make recommendations to support
expanding eligibility as appropriate
this is a good example of the monitoring
of covid19 research that we continue to
do and the adjustments that are made as
evidence emerges
i want to reinforce that while these
medications are important antivirals are
not meant to replace vaccination
the national advisory committee on
immunization has just released updated
recommendations on first booster doses
highlighting that anyone 18 years of age
or over who has not yet received their
first booster which for most people
would be their third dose is strongly
recommended to access the additional
protection this dose offers
in addition as the minister mentioned
those with the most significant risk
factors for severe outcomes are now able
to book second booster doses to enhance
their protection as transmission is
higher in the community
for all of us it is important to
remember that as we're making decisions
every day about how we're living with
covet our actions impact other people as
well
it's important that we all carefully
consider our risk level our level of
comfort and the risk and comfort levels
of those around us
i ask that all of us consider masking in
public places as a prudent step we can
take to protect ourselves and those
around us
we can also look to see coveted 19
trends in our area from our online data
we're updating this data weekly and it's
useful in helping inform the risk level
depending on where we live
i also ask that we please get all doses
of covid19 vaccine that we're eligible
for
these vaccines help prevent serious
outcomes
if you've been infected with covert 19
and still need a first or second booster
we do recommend waiting three months
before you get it
but once that time has passed the
additional dose is important especially
for those with risk factors for severe
outcomes covid will not go away and as
we adjust to living with it i appreciate
everyone's contributions to the balance
of safety and wellness in our
communities that will benefit all of us
thank you and we're happy to take
questions
thanks dr henshaw and minister i think
we've got a couple of reporters just on
the phone no one here in the room in
edmonton and i think not in calgary
either so we'll go to the first caller
please
thank you lauren poland global calgary
hi there thanks for taking my questions
this afternoon um we are of course
heading into the easter long weekend and
it's one of the first major holiday
gatherings we've had since the
transition of learning to live with
covid with relatively no measures in
place uh dr henshaw minister copping
what is your advice to albertans uh
about gathering this easter
egg maybe i'll i'll start just to say
that
we know that covid19 transmission is
higher again is is rising right now and
so it's prude as people think about
the gatherings that they want to
participate in knowing that indoor
social gatherings provide a or they
create a higher risk for transmission if
there's someone infectious who who is
present we also know that people
gain benefit from spending time with
people they care about and it's
important to be able to celebrate
important holidays with
with those of our family and friends
so what i would recommend is that people
consider who they're going to be
gathering with consider what precautions
are appropriate for those individuals
it's critical that anyone who's feeling
sick not attend a gathering consider the
use of rapid tests and
potentially having parts of gatherings
outdoors if the the weather is conducive
on that particular day
so all of the things that we know that
can reduce risk just consider how those
can be incorporated into those
gatherings as we um
again want to keep our the people that
we care about safe and our communities
safe
thanks dr hinshaw lauren do you have a
follow-up
i do thank you also for dr henshaw dr
tam had said yesterday that we are in a
sixth wave and is recommending that we
still wear masks as the ba2 variant
continues to pick up steam we have seen
you what prom had said yesterday that we
are in a sixth wave and is recommending
that we still wear masks as the ba2
variant continues to pick up steam we
have seen you oppressors dr hinshaw
still wearing what it looks like to
masks what it looks like rather is two
masks is that the level of protection
and precaution you are taking in your
day-to-day public activities and do you
recommend that we start wearing masks in
alberta again
it's certainly a prudent step to wear
masks in public places i personally
choose the the mask that i believe is
most appropriate to the activity so
if i'm in a public place with people
that i
don't necessarily know then i would wear
a medical grade mask
if i'm
in
kind of transition and through the
workplace typically i wear
a double cloth mask again because it
provides some protection and so using
the appropriate level of protection
that an individual needs based on their
own risk factors based on the people
that they're with again masking is a
very prudent measure and i would
encourage people to consider again their
context their own risk factors the risk
factors of those around them and the
fact that transmission is rising and to
be a part of protecting our communities
right now masking is a very prudent step
that we can all take thanks dr insha
we'll go to the next caller please
thank you matt woodman ctv
hi there dr hinsha as was just mentioned
dr teresa tam mentioned yesterday that
many areas of the country have now
reached a sixth wave of the pandemic do
you agree with that assessment do you
believe alberta has now reached the
sixth wave
what we've seen throughout the
experience with the pandemic is that we
don't know in advance the specifics of
what we're going to see it's clear that
we have seen a rise in transmission
we've also seen that our positivity
rates have plateaued a bit over the past
week i think it's um
again the the magnitude of this rise how
long it will last those are questions we
don't know the answers to yet um and
then whatever we term it whether it's
called a sixth wave or whether we're
talking about just the the rise in
transmission we've seen we certainly all
know the kinds of things that can help
protect ourselves and those around us
and those are the the same things we've
been talking about for a long time
making sure that we're accessing the
protection that vaccines offer
considering the use of masks washing
hands staying home when sick all of
those things remain important as we
look at at the
conditions in the communities that we
live in
thanks dr henshaw matt you have a
follow-up yeah just a just a quick one
actually uh you mentioned 1053 patients
in hospital with covet 19 right now do
we have an idea of the percentage or how
many of those patients are there because
of covet versus how many are there for
other reasons and later found out they
had cove at once at hospital
we continue to post that information
weekly on our website i
have not looked at the numbers from
yesterday our trends over the past month
or so had been that approximately
uh sort of two-thirds to three-quarters
depending on the time frame we were
looking at and depending if you're
looking at icu or non-icu
were in hospital because of their
coverage infection so either primary or
secondary contributing factor
again i i don't have the numbers
specifically for just the the latest
week period so i'd have to get back to
you on that but they should be available
on our website
thanks for that dr henshaw so we'll take
one more caller i think we have one more
on the line
catherine grakowski alberta today
thanks for taking my question first
questions for dr hinshaw and this is
totally anecdotal but i've heard and
seen a lot of chatter about stomach bugs
going around and i know um the
gastrointestinal symptoms can be a
symptom of covet
but there are also other bugs like e
coli and norovirus and salmonella and
i'm wondering if we're seeing
gastrointestinal symptoms in this
particular strain or if there are other
viruses going around
and what what people should do
if they
are sick with
gastrointestinal symptoms
i don't know i haven't seen evidence
that ba2
causes more gastrointestinal symptoms
than other variants we know throughout
the pandemic there have been some who
when they have a covet 19 infection they
do have symptoms of nausea vomiting
it's not the most common symptom usually
people will have symptoms more
kind of cold or flu-like in terms of
having a sore throat or a cough or a
fever
having said that as you said there are
many things that can cause that kind of
stomach upset
many of which are also very infectious
norovirus for example is is extremely
infectious and it's a good reminder of
the fact that washing hands frequently
is a protection not just against things
like covid19 but a very important
protection against bugs that can cause
those kinds of stomach upsets so
again i would say that we have seen some
evidence that other viruses that have
not been
circulating as much over the past two
years things like influenza
things like norovirus are coming back
perhaps because we're spending more time
together and it's a reminder that these
kinds of precautions that we're taking
that help keep us safe from one virus
can help with other things as well so
again
really just the basics good hand washing
making sure we're staying home if we're
sick no matter what those symptoms are
and again trying to keep ourselves safe
and those around us safe as well
thanks dr insha so final question
catherine supplementary
uh yeah this this one is on a completely
different topic and i'll address it to
health minister uh copying a few news
conferences ago you were asked about the
departure of dr verna yu and you said it
was not about the past six years of her
service but
looking toward the future and i'm
wondering was dr yu's continued uh
tenure in her position incompatible with
the planned health transformations
so
well thanks for the question so no
that's that's not the case uh and first
off i just want to once again uh thank
dr you for her tremendous service
through through very challenging times
uh no this is all really about quite
frankly about timing um we need to do
transformation over the uh in our health
care system you know the alberta
surgical initiative is a key initiative
you know other items we need to address
uh the board and and dr you were well
aware that she was going to be leaving
within it within a year and part of the
challenge is that you know her guiding
the first step of the you know
continuing the the transformation and
handing it over to someone else
on a multi-year program um it presented
some challenging because it'd be someone
else would have to pick up where where
uh where dr you had left off uh and so
you know the conversation between the
the board and dr you was it was
primarily about timing you know getting
someone in there
uh quicker to be able to
lead the transformation not only for for
this year and the changes that we need
to make uh to be able to get caught up
in surgeries uh and be able to bring our
the surgical weight items down to an
acceptable level which is a multi-year
program to have that individual drive
drive through the the entire period so
that was my comments is that you know
when i when i made the comment about
this it wasn't about the past six years
but it's really about the next five
years and having a leader in place uh
that that can consistently drive this
change
over the next five years
thanks for that minister uh we'll wrap
there so thanks to you and dr hinshaw
and we'll see you here next week